[संगीत]
अपने बांके की किस्मत में भी रंग भर दो
भगवान। कब तक ब्लैक एंड वाइट रखोगे?
बांके भाई
आधा लीटर नीला, आधा लीटर पीला और 100
मिलीलीटर काला रंग दे दो।
अभी लाया।
[संगीत]
कैसे हो बांके भाई? यह नया धंधा कब शुरू
किया?
कुछ ही दिन हुए हैं। तू बता क्या चाहिए?
अरे तुम तो जानते हो बांके भाई। अपना काम
रंगों से खेलने का है। एक बड़ा बोल्ड पेंट
करना है। आधा-आधा लीटर के चार रंग दे दो।
लाल, हरा, पीला और सफेद।
अभी लाया।
[संगीत]
अब से यहीं से खरीदना कलर बढ़िया
डिस्काउंट मिलेगा।
बिल्कुल बांके भाई।
[प्रशंसा]
[संगीत]
भाई साहब पेंट होगा आपके पास? नहीं भाई
साहब। मैं पटाखे बेचता हूं। यह इतने बड़े
बोर्ड पर बड़े-बड़े अक्षरों में लिखा है बां
के रंगीला पेंट शॉप।
जी गलती हो गई मुझे जरा। बस को पेंट करने
का रंग चाहिए था। पीली और सफेद रंग का।
मिल जाएगा। कितना दूं?
5- 5 लीटर दे दीजिए।
[संगीत]
ओ भाई साहब कैसा रंग है ये लगाने से पहले
छूट जाता है
अरे बांके भाई क्या एक्सपायर माल बेचकर
लोगों को चूना लगा रहे हो चार बार बोर्ड
पर कलर करने के बाद भी पता ही नहीं चल रहा
है कि कभी इस पर पेंट भी किया था कि नहीं
ओ भाई साहब, कैसा घटिया पेंट दिया है। बस
पर जो पहले कलर था वो भी उतर गया है। पैसे
वापस करो मेरे।
ये दुकान बंद करो और सड़क पर मूंगफली
बेचने का काम शुरू करो। पता नहीं कौन सा
एक्सपायर माल चिपका रहे हो लोगों को। इससे
ज्यादा पक्का रंग तो थूके हुए पान का होता
है। वापस करो मेरे पैसे।
[संगीत]
लगता है यह धंधा भी बंद हो जाएगा।
ओ महाशय कैसा केमिकल बना कर दिया है मुझे
जिस भी रंग में मिला रहा हूं पानी की तरह
छूट रहा है।
आपने पहले नहीं बताया ना कि कौन से रंग
में मिलाओगे केमिकल?
कौन से रंग में मिलाऊंगा मतलब? अरे रंग तो
रंग होता है।
नहीं भाई साहब कपड़ों का अलग होता है।
दीवारों पर जो रंग होता है वो अलग होता
है। लोहे की चीजों पर जो होता है वो अलग
होता है।
बस बस बस मुझे ऐसा केमिकल दो जो जिस भी
रंग में मिला हूं तो जल्दी से ना छूटे
समझे। जैसी आपकी मर्जी।
[संगीत]
अरे पप्पू भाई क्या बात है? कहां जा रहे
हो? पास तो आओ।
मुझे तो लगा तुमने दुकान बंद कर दी होगी।
कैसी बात कर रहे हो? रंगने के लिए रंग
चाहिए।
अपने पास रखो अपने ये कच्चे रंग। मुझे
मेरा धंधा चौपट नहीं करना है।
एक बार ले जाओ। अगर रंग ना टिके तो पैसे
मत देकर जाना। अभी फ्री ले जाओ। काम हो
जाए तो पैसे दे जाना।
ठीक है। तुम कहते हो तो मान लेता हूं। दे
दो आधा लीटर लाल और सफेद।
[संगीत]
क्या बात है बांके भाई मान गए इस बार रंग
बड़े पक्के हैं बोर्ड पर अलग ही चमक आ रही
है मान गए गुरु
बस अब बाकी लोग भी मान जाए बांके रंगीला
को
मान जाएंगे बांके भाई मैं तो तुमसे ही
पेंटिंग के लिए रंग लूंगा बाकी लोगों को
भी बोल दूंगा रंग लो तो अपने बांके भाई से
ही
[प्रशंसा]
बांके भाई भाई पप्पू पेंटर ने बताया अबकी
बार आपने सबसे अलग रंग मंगाया है। जरा
दीजिए एक मेहरून रंग का डिब्बा।
मुझे भी एक लीटर काला रंग।
एक बार जो लगाए बांके के रंग मिल जाए उसके
जीवन में रंग।
चल मैं आ।
अरे थोड़ेथ थोड़े 10 मिनट हो गए हैं। अब आई
जल्दी करो भाई।
[संगीत]
अरे बांके भाई क्या हाल है?
हाल तो बढ़िया है पप्पू भाई। कौन सा रंग दे
दूं?
रंग लेने नहीं खबर देने आया हूं।
कैसी खबर?
रंगों का कंपटीशन हो रहा है गांव में।
जिसके रंग सबसे पक्के और बढ़िया होंगे उनको
इनाम मिलेगा। नंबर लगा दो अपना भी।
ये खबर मेरे बिज़नेस में चार चांद लगा
देगी। अब पप्पू भाई कहां जाकर नाम देना
है? यह रहा भर के साइन कर दो। जमा मैं कर
दूंगा दोस्ती के लिए। अगली बार डिस्काउंट
50% कर देना कलर पर।
इस बार अगर यह अवार्ड मिल गया तो वो अरे
न्यारे हो जाएंगे प्रभु। अब फिर दुकान
नहीं रंगों की फैक्ट्री खोलूंगा। अपने
रंगों को और ठीक करने के लिए और केमिकल
लेकर आ जाता हूं।
क्या हाल है भाई साहब?
बताइए भाई साहब। क्या दूं? रंग पक्का करने
का केमिकल।
अभी थोड़े दिन पहले तो आप ले गए थे। उसने
काम नहीं किया क्या जो इतनी जल्दी आ गए?
अरे मैं जल्दी आऊं या देर से? सुबह आऊं या
सवेरे से? तुम्हें क्या मतलब? तुम पैसों
से मतलब रखो ना और जल्दी से रंग पक्का
करने का केमिकल दो।
[संगीत]
ये लो भाई साहब।
ये लो पैसे। अगली बार आने जाने का नहीं
पैसों का हिसाब रखना।
[संगीत]
[प्रशंसा]
बांके भाई बांके भाई अरे ये दुनिया बेच कर
सो रहे हो क्या? कुछ देर के लिए तो लगा कि
दुनिया से चले ही गए। जल्दी से गांव को
इकट्ठा करो शोर मचा कर।
अबे दोस्त होकर दुश्मनों जैसी बातें कर
रहा है। शक्ल अच्छी नहीं है तो बात तो
अच्छी कर लिया कर। अभी मेरी उम्र ही क्या
है जो दुनिया से जाऊं? बोल, क्यों गला
फाड़ रहा था?
बांके भाई सबकी दुकान के रंग रिजेक्ट कर
दिए हैं अवार्ड वालों ने। लगता है
तुम्हारा नंबर लग जाएगा। जल्दी से बढ़िया
सा पक्के रंग का डब्बा तैयार रखो। वो लोग
आते ही होंगे तुम्हारी दुकान पर।
[संगीत]
तुम्हारा नाम यह बांके रंगीला है।
हां जी। ऊपर बोर्ड पर भी लिखा है।
रंग चेक कराइए।
तुम्हारा पट जिस भी चीज पर होगा उसकी उम्र
बढ़ा देगा। हम आपको इस अवार्ड के लिए
फाइनल कर रहे हैं।
क्या बात है बांके भैया एकदम निशाने पर
लगाए तीर।
बस एक बार पूरे गांव के सामने वोट मिल जाए
फिर गांव में ही नहीं शहर में भी मेरी
दुकान होगी।
होगी बांके भैया बिल्कुल होगी। अच्छा एक
बात बताओ, होली आ रही है और दुकान में
सिर्फ यही रंग बेचोगे। होली रंग भी लाओ
खुशबू वाले। होली में एक्स्ट्रा इनकम के
लिए। बात तो सही है पप्पू आज ही जाकर रंग
लेकर आता हूं।
आज भी रंग पक्का करने की बोतल देनी है भाई
साहब।
आज पक्के नहीं कच्चे रंग लेने आया हूं।
होली के रंग गुलाबी, लाल, खुशबूदार जल्दी
से सारा सामान दे दो।
[संगीत]
[प्रशंसा]
ये लो भाई साहब। यह पैकेट में रंग बनाने
का पाउडर है और यह अलग से खुशबू के केमिकल
है। थोड़ा-थोड़ा मिला देना।
बस बस समझ गया। ये लो पैसे फिर मिलते हैं।
[संगीत]
जितनी ज्यादा खुशी उतना महंगा बिकेगा मेरा
रंग। जल्दी से सारे रंग सजा देता हूं
दुकान के सामने।
बांके भाई सबसे पहले मैं ही लूंगा रंग। कल
है होली जल्दी से दे दो रंग।
वाह शाबाश बांके। आज तो सारे रंग बिक गए।
कल होली पर होगा आराम और उसके बाद ही
खुलेगी दुकान।
[प्रशंसा]
[संगीत]
क्यों बे बाखे? कौन सा रंग लगवा दिया
हमारे मुंह पर। कल से रगड़ रहे हैं और
छूटने का नाम ही नहीं ले रहा है।
मुझे तो डॉक्टर ने बोला है प्लास्टिक
सर्जरी करनी होगी।
मेरे तो बीवी बच्चे मुझे नहीं पहचान रहे
हैं भाई। यह सब इस बांके की वजह से हुआ
है। इसकी दुकान के सारे रंग इस पर डाल दो।
भाग बांके वरना तेरी होली हो जाएगी।
[संगीत]
तो